right here we go all smiles from the g7
as the group welcomes president
joe biden with open arms quite a
different scene from 2018
when donald trump was in charge remember
that he didn't seem like he was being
welcomed there and he didn't seem to
mind it
no wonder from the moment the joe biden
touched down in canvas bay
he was on board with the plans of the
world community of the g7 to make
everyone go green and sign on to the
iran deal
again and it was bad in 2015 and it's
even worse now
molly hemingway is the senior editor of
the federalists you know her
hey molly aren't these the policies that
got donald trump elected in the first
place
well i think what's happening at this g7
summit really does show the difference
between donald trump's america first
foreign policy and what the biden
administration offers
these people are praising joe biden not
because he's good for america but
because he's good
for them and they like that he is going
to
increase you know have these troops in
europe fund their defense
you know let russia have its pipeline
through germany all these things that
they wanted and they flattered him and
then they
then they get it but a lot of people
wonder what how that works out well for
the american taxpayer who ends up having
to foot the bill and dealing with these
you know trade agreements that are
decades old and need to be updated but
won't be
but joe biden gets flattered and so
everything goes back to normal
right uh so he took about five or six
questions today last about 20 minutes
one of the questions about domestic
politics here's uh
the republican party came up here's how
here's the question
here's his answer i want your response
the leadership of the republican party
is
fractured and the
trump wing of the party is the bulk of
the party
but it makes up a significant minority
of the american people
so i i think it is
a shock and surprise that what's
happened
in terms of the consequence of president
trump's phony populism
phony populism smaller party fractured
party and he started by saying
uh one of the question was about january
6. what is what are the rest of the
countries talking about january 6
and donald trump's responsibility there
what's your response to his response
well joe biden took hours to get to this
press conference then he took like five
pre-selected questions and used the
opportunity to bash his fellow
countrymen
because apparently for a lot of people
in the leadership in the democratic
party the biggest enemies are the people
in the opposing party
but what's more concerning than the
venue of when he decided to attack his
fellow americans
is he's just wrong i mean the republican
party is at record
levels in terms of it's had more people
voting for it than ever before there
were 10 million plus new voters
in this election that he just won they
the democrats
lost seats in the house republicans
gained seats in the house
and these ideas that the republican
party is talking about this
new look at foreign policy and focusing
on the american worker are actually
quite popular and i think he knows that
that's why he's trying to denigrate
these things
but if the republican party does stick
to those policy wins that they've had in
the recent years of re-looking at these
things
i think he knows that they are a big
threat and i think that's why he's
trying to tear them down
molly it's so easy to sidestep that
question especially overseas
you get worried about people
domestically comment about the president
overseas it's not a great look
it's kind of rare to see a a american
president overseas
ripping another party at home
well i remember you had sometimes donald
trump would be doing this and people
would just
really react negatively to it but they
forget that you know here's joe biden
doing it barack obama he seemed to love
to go overseas and attack republicans it
was like
his favorite thing to do um what's
different i think is when the media gets
upset about it and when they don't but
in general it would be good if all
presidents
kept the domestic stuff at home and
really focused on these
important foreign policy things i mean
joe biden needs to remember
the american taxpayer and what they are
being asked to do in terms of
subsidizing european defense
and in subsidizing these trade deals and
he's just keeping them on the back
burner
for petty political reasons and that's
unfortunate and the problem is with
multilateralism
is that you have to get everybody's
opinion on board and that's why all
these
communiques are so watered down when it
comes to russia
and certainly china leaving out of the
g7 uh
very curious his whole trip is going to
be defined on how it goes with vladimir
putin
but so far we're four days in and that's
what we have
thanks so much molly appreciate it thank
you all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else